hello everybody and welcome to the lab
roots webinar
genomics landscapes leveraging genetic
evidence throughout the pharma pipeline
my name is mark keel i'm the founder and
chief science officer at genominon
and i'll be walking you through at a
high level
what genomic landscapes are and how they
inform
effectiveness in the drug discovery
pipeline
the way i've structured the webinar is
to first outline outline why
genomics is beneficial for
pharmaceutical companies
seeking to develop drugs or bring those
drugs to market
by going through the core benefits and
the applications of genomics
in each of those aspects next i'm going
to talk about
how genomic landscapes are assembled and
how they can play a role in facilitating
those aspects of drug discovery
and finally i'm going to walk through
several representative case studies
of genomic landscapes that my team has
put together
for a variety of different use cases for
our pharmaceutical clients
before i get started i want to mention
that
genominon offers the mastermind genomics
search engine
free of charge in its basic edition form
but through the context of this webinar
are offering access to the professional
version which is useful for diagnosing
genetic variants
in clinical circumstances as well as for
performing in-depth research
to help drive your drug discovery
indications
but first let me begin with the why i'll
talk at a very high level
about how genomics is increasingly
playing a role
in drug discovery and drug development
by walking through the core benefits
and touching upon some of the principal
applications
of this new data
this is the main walk away slide from
the talk that i'm going to give and it's
been born out of a number of
meta-analyses that are collected from a
number of primary
research studies that indicate that
having genetically supported targets
can double the success rate for clinical
development of a therapeutic compound
this quote is taken from a recent paper
in nature genetics from 2015
but there have subsequently been
multiple studies corroborating
and um deepening this this finding
so to to itemize some of the benefits of
genomics
in facilitating drug discovery its
application
can be broken down into three rough
camps
one is in facilitating understanding of
complex
or otherwise heterogeneous diseases
by helping researchers find
activating or loss of function mutations
that drive disease
and are thereby amenable to therapeutic
intervention
another aspect um where genomics has
shown a great deal of promise
is in bringing together multiple
disparate or seemingly disparate disease
types
that actually are related at a genetic
or genomic level
so having those different diseases
converge around a unified treatment
strategy
which is obviously very useful and
applicable in drug repurposing
aspects of developing markets for
previously vetted and developed drug
compounds
and the last aspect where genomics has
shown up a promising role
is in treatment of conditions with
significant genetic heterogeneity so
whether
there's pathway heterogeneity that can
be then resolved by genomics
or otherwise where there's homogeneity
in the disease development for a given
indication
that with other w was otherwise not
known that can be uncovered through
genomic research
more specifically the application of
genomics to pharma
can empower a number of different
aspects spanning the gamut from early
drug discovery all the way to
post-commercialization activities
one of those ways is in optimizing
pre-clinical therapeutic targets
by better understanding the disease
causing mechanism at the genetic or
genomic level
that affords a more precise targeted
approach
to developing those therapeutic
compounds
this in turn can greatly reduce the
upfront r d
costs not only by streamlining the
analysis
but by better prioritizing which of
those candidate compounds
has the best likelihood of becoming a
successful drug brought to market
moving toward the middle of the drug
development pipeline
bringing genomics to bear can maximize
the likely success of the conduct of
clinical trials
both in the early stages of the design
of those trials
as well as throughout the conduct of
those trials
and finally in the post-hoc analysis
once all of the data
with respect to response to drug
treatment
is has been assembled genomics can help
reconcile some of that otherwise
seemingly disparate information by
putting a finer point
on who's responding or who's not
responding and why
similarly um toward the latter stage of
the drug development pipeline
having the full breadth of this genetic
and genomic information
around a given indication can help
expedite
fda approval processes
and likewise having this comprehensive
understanding of the nature
size and identity of your patients
comprising your target market having all
this evidence
assembled through genomics can decrease
that time to market as well as expand
your market size so let's
talk a little bit more about what i mean
when i say genetics or genomics in the
context of drug discovery
so many of you have have perhaps heard
about the bioinformatic bottleneck
which confounds the use of this
sequencing information that we're
increasingly able to access
cheaply and very efficiently
part of the challenge with collecting
such big data sets for any of our
drug discovery paradigms is that
somebody some group needs to look at and
interpret that information
so this bioinformatic bottleneck has
often been referred to as the thousand
dollar genome
but the million dollar interpretation so
where sequencing is no longer the rate
limiting step
and is extremely cost effective to the
point of being commoditized
there's still this attendant
interpretation challenge
where understanding the data and
rendering that interpretation
largely at this point has to occur
through a manual data
interpretation and curation process
so what is needed to break this
bottleneck
to inform the relevance of that genomic
data
for the application in the context of
precision medicine
so what is needed to fully understand
these studies is a comprehensive
understanding of genomic biomarkers
and that breaks down into roughly three
camps and i've
categorized and described them here as
the diagnostic utility
of the the genetic information driving
precision medicine studies
and that the requirements there are that
it be clinical grade
industry standard and go down to the
variant level
which requires a great deal of energy
and information to make the most
accurate interpretation on an individual
variant
as well as make the most comprehensive
interpretation
of an entire cohort's worth of genetic
information
attendant to that diagnostic requirement
is the requirement that you understand
functionally what's going on
at the hand of genetic variants that are
leading to disease development
and that includes identifying all of the
empirical studies
that may have been articulated by
researchers over previous decades
of scientific inquiry uncovering that
information
and putting it into the context of
disease
mechanisms as well as treatment
strategies
is absolutely required for fully
understanding the genetic information
as it drives precision medicine studies
and finally
understanding how treatments are
efficacious or failed to lead to
efficacy
collecting all of the previous empirical
evidence
whether it be from other researchers or
from your own
uh organization's work that is requisite
to fully understand how genomics plays
into
understanding and driving precision
medicine studies
so the problem with addressing each of
those three aspects
is that extracting and interpreting this
complicated
uh disparate and often ambiguous genetic
information
at present required a human
and what i'm here to talk to you about
is how janomenon
is minimizing the requirement that a
human
organize and extract this information
so instead they can focus on
interpreting that information
so the real question here is how do we
do that
we've coined the phrase genomic
landscape based on the assembled data
that we've accumulated over many years
of practice
that is promulgated in the mastermind
genomic database
which includes information from
population
data for variant allele frequencies
as well as predictive models of
pathogenic mechanisms
for each of these variants and
critically all of this
empirical information patterned in the
decades of
scientific research that put together
comprises the corpus of information in
the mastermind database
which is indexed at multiple levels
at the gene level at the variant level
at the disease level at the phenotype
level
and at the the therapeutic level by
looking at all of the different ways
that authors can describe
each of those entities and putting
together the
the indexed information into bio
association data and then using that
information
to drive the development of these
genomic landscapes
so let's let's revisit what i mean to
say uh by bio
associations so on the left here you see
a hexagonal representation of the
different ways of
looking at all of that evidence at the
top and one of the more challenging
pieces and also the most valuable in
many circumstances
to extract meaningful information from
this empirical
evidence are the variant level
annotations in the
databases and in the published
literature but similarly
those variants can be associated with
diseases
phenotypes therapies obviously
genes at the gene level there may be
informative
information on how the genes are
associated with disease development
or how those diseases that arise at the
result of mutations in those genes
can be targeted therapeutically so that
entire
network on top of any custom configured
queries
such as say prevalence information in
diseased cohorts
all of that information and more is
pre-patterned in the mastermind database
where the strength of any of these
assertions can be bolstered
by the multiplicity of different and
disparate types of
associations that um that are uncovered
through the mastermind
data so the way that janomenon
provides value to pharma clients is by
organizing all this evidence and
identifying
associations that were otherwise unknown
to our clients
or otherwise emphasizing the strength
and evidence
underpinning known associations that
drive drug discovery and drug
development
so a bit of a behind the scenes as to
how we do
this genomic interpretation at such
scale
the main takeaway here is that it's a
unique two-phasic approach
where we combine computational
intelligence
to organize and annotate and prepare
this information
for human review followed by a maximally
efficient
expedited expert curation that can be
tailored to specific disease contexts
or specific client requirements
and what results in many of those cases
an example of which i'm showing here
is a comprehensive and exhaustively
annotated compendium of information
that has been toplined uh and supported
by granular level evidence
so that the data and the information is
immediately
actionable and there's immediate walk
away insight from that accumulated
evidence
but you can also drill very deep to the
primary source of that evidence
in many cases which is to say from the
empirical literature
so i'm highlighting this example here
for a constitutional
gene in the context of
germline variants that cause cancer each
of these rows is one of those variants
with the assembled information
categorized and summarized as well as
exhaustively
curated and annotated down to the level
of individual reference citations
similarly this is an example on the
somatic side
for identifying functional variants in
the atm
gene where we proceeded in the same
manner
and pulled out all of the evidence in
this case
really focusing on the functional
evidence annotating that information in
a way that was meaningful to the client
and showing our work effectively by
providing
the the necessary and annotated
reference citations
so the benefit of these comprehensive
genomic landscapes which is to say
all of the variants associated with a
given gene or a gene pathway
or otherwise all of the genes associated
with a given
disease or indication and any other way
that you can slice the
the data that mastermind is indexed
around those
genomic landscapes are useful to drive
research and discovery drug discovery
organizing real world evidence focusing
on drug repurposing
all the way to the conduct of uh and
design of clinical trials
including promulgation of a companion
diagnostic
so hopefully that gives you a high level
view of what we mean when we say a
genomic landscape
i want to drill into some specific
representative case studies
and how they were used to derive
value in the context of drug discovery
by
leveraging this wealth of information in
genomics
so i think i have three examples and
they can be
broken down this is a a deeper view into
the drug
discovery pipeline they can be broken
down into multiple
different use cases the couple that i'm
going to focus on here
are in new target assessment defining
the mechanism of action from these
genomic landscapes
supporting the clinical trial candidacy
of a given target
as well as providing that regulatory
support
the evidence compendium that i alluded
to that can really expedite
fda submissions so the first case study
i want to talk about
involves the larc ii gene and the task
at hand or the use of this genomic
landscape data
is in new target assessment
so basically by new target assessment i
mean understanding the molecular basis
of disease
really underscoring how this pathway
either through the individual gene or
its neighboring
protein participants is contributing to
the development of the disease
with a view toward providing a molecular
starting point for targeted therapy
or otherwise discovering attendant
biomarkers
that are either disease-causing or have
bearing on
how a patient may respond to therapy
so this is a summary summary of the
fruits of the work that
resulted from assembling the lark ii
genomic landscape
just to orient you to the plot here each
of those
icons is of an individual variant
for which there's either one paper
usually one patient or otherwise many
hundreds of papers
that all comprise in aggregate the the
comprehensive genomic landscape for larp
ii the top plot was actually
what was known about larp 2 and its
disease-causing variants
before we began the work to assemble
this comprehensive genomic landscape
in total they number 22 and at the
result of completing this genomic
landscape
we had fully a six-fold increase in the
number of those variants
which had clinical grade evidence
empirical evidence from the
peer-reviewed literature
to support their candidacy for
diagnostic purposes for patients who
have parkinson's at the hand of these
larp2 mutations
so one other thing i want to emphasize
here is how
the benefit of a comprehensive
understanding
of the genomic landscape can really
clarify
and have emerge patterns that were
otherwise
not possible uh given the the sort of
shallow look into the genomic landscape
that's afforded
by by simply looking manually for this
evidence
so you can see in the armadillo domain
of larp2 as well as in the wd-40 domain
in addition to the rock domain and some
of the other functional domains of vlar2
there's just not enough evidence that
was known beforehand
to elucidate any of these patterns that
then
obviously have bearing on the patients
that are likely to respond to a targeted
therapeutic
as well as the mechanism of disease
causation at the hand of mutations in
this protein
so to get more in depth at since we're
talking in this context about
a new target characterization
each of those variants that was
identified in the process of assembling
this genomic landscape
was assessed for having any functional
studies that clarified what those
variants were doing at the protein level
so uh some subset of those variants that
were uncovered
had attendant in vitro or in vivo
studies
where the authors were interrogating
what functional consequence each had
on protein function and that information
is depicted here
where again each dot is a variant
on the top aspect of this plot are
variants which have bearing on gtpa's
activity
and on the bottom variants that had
bearing on kinase activity
where lr2 is an interesting gene in that
it has both gain of function and loss of
function consequences
where each of those different types of
changes in each of those functional
outputs for this protein were
characterized
again from the multiplicity of empirical
studies
from the medical literature so in total
out of the
the many hundreds of variants that were
uncovered in this
process there were about a hundred that
had any of this functional
evidence that was exhaustively annotated
and organized
to to result in this plot for better
understanding lord 2 in the context of
disease development
and therefore drug response
the next example that i want to go to i
gave a hint to
in in the description of what a genomic
landscape is
and that's to say let's better
understand
the mechanism of action for loss of
function mutations in atm
which is a tumor suppressor and for
which there are
loss of function mutations such as non
nonsense and frame shift mutations
whose consequence to protein function is
is pretty straightforward
let's better understand what missense
mutations
may confer loss of function to really
understand
how the protein is working and thereby
better
understand how best to target the
consequences
of that loss of function leading to
cancer
so writ more broadly mechanism of action
is something that um uh genomics
genomic landscapes can help better
understand to allow
clients to focus more on high-yield
candidates or decrease the failure rate
from investing energy into uh targets
that don't have
the supporting genetic and genomic
evidence that i alluded to earlier
as well as say saving on opportunity
costs
or producing more innovative and more
informed clinical trial designs
so this is a summary slide for the
fruits of the atm
data that we produced while putting
together the comprehensive genomic
landscape
so atm is you can see is a quite large
gene
it has multiple ways to have loss of
function given its its multiple
functions
each of those dots now is curated
from the evidence of any one of these
references that
cites atm and highlighted in blue there
are any and every one of those variants
from one study to hundreds of studies
that had any functional evidence
whatsoever
all arrayed along the linear axis of the
protein domains in
atm so the work that we began here
began with very little insight into the
function
or the the consequence of any of these
missense variants
and what resulted after finally
assembling this work
uh was nearly 300 of the the variants
that had any of that functional evidence
thoroughly annotated
uh and categorized according to which
functions
of atm those variants were seen to be
affecting
so to to top line this we in this
process
uncover a great burden of evidence that
was otherwise opaque
to our client to help them better
determine
how atm is functioning in the
development of
the the diseases that that are caused by
mutations in this protein
so the third example uh has to do with
the application of genomic landscapes
in um producing a companion list of
variants
where their candidacy for inclusion in
clinical trials is supported by
evidence from the genomic landscape
so clinical trial candidacy and the
application of genomic landscapes in
that service
uh allows clients to use genomic
biomarkers
as inclusion or exclusion criteria
based on the evidence that's uncovered
in the process of developing that
landscape
in establishing a companion diagnostic
with this molecular information
or otherwise to ensure a more
homogeneous patient cohort
and thereby increasing the drug response
rate
in addition to adding statistical power
to your study
by bringing in the right members of a
lead cohort as you're starting to embark
on a clinical trial to
to test drug efficacy
so lepar as you as some of you may know
has to do with the development of
monogenic obesity it's one of several
genes
that in this process of assembling a
genomic landscape
we uncovered uh the the the work that we
did here
began with an understanding of about
three genes
and maybe a dozen disease-causing
variants
and just like i talked to uh at the
beginning how that
hexagonal interconnected network of
information in mastermind
we were able to ask of our data
what other genes are associated with the
development of various forms of
monogenic obesity
and took that list of known genes that
were causative from three
to nearly 50 and took that list of known
variants that
that caused disease development from 12
to
many hundreds in this case a 55 fold in
increase in the number of variants that
again according to clinical standards
were
were suitable for enrolling patients
onto a clinical trial
so in this case in particular in many
similar cases like it
since we developed this um this data set
genomic can dramatically increase
patient enrollment
and and smooth the um the operations and
conduct of a clinical trial
to ensure a maximally successful likely
outcome
the the one thing that i wanted to point
out on this slide you'll notice that
there are
red variants a rate along the one gene
for an example lepar gene
as well as open red circles for likely
pathogenic variants
the gray circles there represent the
other variants again in addition to the
660
that were known to be pathogenic that we
uncovered in this process
there's still a groundswell of
additional information
in the form of variants that don't yet
meet the
clinical criteria to be called
pathogenic
but may at any moment with a new
publication
either a functional study or a clinical
study or a case report
may turn into likely pathogenic or
pathogenic variants
based on that new information and so i
don't want to
just focus on the immediately actionable
information
without highlighting the fact that this
literature and this information
is constantly growing and that
phenomenon in the in the production of
these genomic landscapes
keeps abreast of that information in
real time
so the last example i've again i've
already alluded to this
briefly is in assembling a comprehensive
genomic landscape
for regulatory support for a companion
diagnostic for the rep gene
and establishing objectivity with
genetic evidence for your candidates
is useful at a baseline for supporting
materials for your fda submission but it
gets much more detailed and more
exhaustive than that when you're talking
about
using biomarkers genetic and genomic
biomarkers
to develop this companion diagnostic
which is what i wanted to talk about
here
in the context of rat so again to orient
you this is the rep
protein with all of its functional
domains at the top
those triangles are where we began our
client began
in their engagement with us
understanding the disease causing
variance in ret
and we tripled and then some
the number of variants with clinical
grade evidence from
the uh the medical literature and
associated databases
that were sufficient um to include on
the the client's companion diagnostic so
we went from about 38
known activating variants in the context
of hereditary cancer
for which the group had a targeted
therapeutic
to 130 variants with with
known activation mechanism of action
with all of the evidence necessary to
support their candidacy
again in clinical levels i'll highlight
there
that the benefit is in expansion of your
market
uh comprising your companion diagnostic
as well as
providing this exhaustive compendium of
information
to support your regulatory submission
but also
the idea that a comprehensive landscape
can
illuminate patterns that were otherwise
not apparent
in in previous iterations where there's
just a dearth of information
that's insufficient to to showcase those
patterns so you can see there
a couple of those variant um uh regions
are piling up and showcasing
in both the kinase domains as well as in
the
the cysteine rich domains there in rhett
patterns that didn't otherwise exist
um weren't weren't apparent to our
client
uh lastly i'll emphasize here in in the
deliverable
that the evidence is tiered so we we
pres
provide in the case of each of these
variant landscapes
a provisional call by the prevailing
clinical standard either acmg
for constitutional disease or amp for
somatic disease
producing a comprehensive list of all of
these variants
adjudicated according to those standards
by reviewing all of those references
and categorizing and enumerating all of
that evidence
for ease of access and searching and
sorting and filtering
and then providing the granular level
reference citations
with sentence context from each of those
authors
to justify any scientific assertions
that we make
so that was the last slide that i wanted
to give before i reiterate that
mastermind
the data is available in a genomic
search engine format for clinical
purposes
as well as to drive some research
aspects
for drug discovery that can then be
greatly expedited and
deepened by engaging phenomenon in the
production
of one of these genomic landscapes but
for access to the genomic search engine
you need only follow that link below and
following that link will afford you
access to the mastermind professional
edition
which is most suitable for some of those
activities that i described
clinical duties and some of the sort of
baseline research studies that you
you might be interested in before
engaging in the production of a
comprehensive genomic landscape
so with that i'll i'll conclude and and
thank you for attending the webinar
uh it's recorded so i won't take any
questions live obviously but
i will be available um during the the
actual
conference to answer any questions that
emerge
or otherwise we can be reached at hello
genominon.com
if you'd like to learn more about what i
described in this webinar
so thanks again and with that i'll
conclude